he is the pride of Omaha Nebraska who
first got a big break in the movie
election way back in the day played
Harvey Dent and Gotham for three seasons
also was on heroes and now is in season
2 playing the role of John Segal in
trial and error on NBC versus John
Lithgow in season 1 and now Christian
Chenoweth and season - good to see you
Nicholas de agosto thank you all of that
made me feel like
those're did the time go and I didn't
even hit all your credit yeah no well
there's not a whole lot I mean some of
them shouldn't be hit well I mean for a
show like this one as well going to
Marquette at the same time as Dwayne
Wade is up there as well yeah my first
dream when I moved out yeah well my
first year when when I moved out to LA
2002 2002 to 2003 he took Marquette to
the Final Four that year
yes and I was watching it down I didn't
know where to go I happened to be like
dad I was gonna go to Santa Monica and
go along the boardwalk tied like the
third Street or fourth Street Promenade
down there and I stepped into a bar down
there and watched that the final four
game which if you remember not a
successful game but before that well I
mean you can also with so many New York
transplants here in this town we could
throw a stone and hit a Syracuse grads
yeah that's right that was was that that
was it Marquette vs. Turkey I know
Marquette wants to Kansas ah loss to
Kansas but I think they beat Kentucky
actually in the eighth no eating I think
that was the big thing was like the blue
blood win over Kentucky was huge and now
I mean he is he's a first-ballot
hall-of-famer
yeah and he's amazing and I I've had the
fortune of meeting up at some you know
some party where we were you know in
wrapping a show no I was older than him
but no he he's he was just a very sweet
man you know I met him out at some
Hollywood thing and and I accosted him
and was like I'm a fan yes and I was
just totally dork about it and he was
very nice and he's used to that sort of
thing and he was great and because of
that I became a kind of LeBron fan
because
as you know being from Omaha Nebraska
there's no professional sports team so
it took me a while to kind of find my
way to like what would be an NBA team I
like but you're mandated to be a
Cornhusker right yeah oh yeah Brandon
correct yeah branded it yeah they
branded all children like they brand
their cattle
so you've got I'm not gonna show you
that either I'm good I'm glad that
you're sitting down um so Scott Frost
was on the show a couple of weeks yeah
watch that yeah and he is ready to
return
yeah man prominence that Tom Osborne
obviously brought to Nebraska so you
must be fired up about that yeah I think
it's like I'm really fired up about it I
was actually getting a chance to talk to
Bruce in the greenroom area before
because I had the opportunity to sort of
just pick his brain a little bit about
it and what happened after he well so he
interviewed him for the Sports
Illustrated article that was a big you
know extensive article on Scott frost
return to Nebraska and all this stuff
and and and I don't know it's got frost
at all but I he's such an intelligent
man listen to and clearly so and such a
such a revered son for anyone which is
like 79 percent of the people in
Nebraska love Nebraska football and so
and the other 21 percent just traveled
too much I guess I don't but I they but
you know he's such a wonderful man to
listen to you know he's kind of Mark's
all these boxes that you want your coach
to be at that level which is someone
that's an upstanding citizen a family
man and just a true competitor who's
clearly very intelligent at what he does
and knows the program yeah I mean all
right few years national championship
winner when I was 17 when I saw him did
you ask got this and Scott had the
wonderful avoid he dodged the bullet
again as Tom Osborne
would say it took a knee he took a knee
on that okay that's fair and me he did
he did give you a little indication
which was it was this veiled this veiled
jab which was I'm pretty sure any
fanbase of a team that was that
successful and that strong would believe
that their team would have beat the
other team or something like that and I
was like that's a very you know a very
classy move just shows the class that
this man is gonna bring to the program
also that
he respects your program yes and I
respect this this challenge that's one
way to view that how could it all save
me at may I give you the other the other
way is well Tom Osborne with retirees
and the members of the media wanted to
give him the mother of all gold watch
which is half of Michigan's championship
Wow and the reason why we even had a
half of a championship is because the
touchdown pass in quotes that I threw
against Missouri that got kicked up in
the air purposefully against the rules
that's true it was admitted to later
laminae was it Matt Davison absolutely
yeah who's now part of the organization
there in Nebraska that brought Scott
frost back yeah that's the reason why we
got half a champion that's that's what I
was reading into what he was saying at
the time Nikolas all right now that I
think that's entirely fair but I'm not
sure I'm not sure it's good way to read
the entire Congress okay but I will say
yes that Nebraska shared a national
championship with Penn State no it was
at Penn State
yeah it was Penn State yes and Penn
State had a controversial call where the
man the receiver later admitted to being
out of bounds when he caught that yes
that kept them alive in that game so I
will say that we all know how college
football works yes and I can't go
through all of Michigan's plays from
that season yes and I don't remember how
close they were to like the what the the
average like when the difference were
close they were not very close this is
also yeah I recognize that yes but yes
the thing that he's undeniable yes there
were two strong undefeated teams just
from top tier programs yes and Nebraska
had a massive win against a very strong
Peyton Manning Tennessee team that year
yes and it was very difficult to say
that Nebraska is not an excellent
program or not an excellent team that
season I will say continuing this
high-pitched cadence that we are going
back and forth to maintain stability I
will say that Michigan did have the
actual Heisman Trophy winner over Peyton
Manning then your intro Woodson right
and with respect to you as a guest on
this show yeah first of what I hope as
many appearances Nicholas Gus I would
love to come back I'll come back
tomorrow I will say
I don't care what happens ween Nebraska
and Penn State yeah no I respect this
but I look I get it I get it
can I just respect each other I guess I
love the passion and and how can I say
that you don't have a right to ask for
that but you know I all I know is is
that that was that was a very fine team
and as a Nebraska fan I was all too
happy to see us be a part of them and I
think the ultimate trump of this whole
thing is that you are a fresh-faced star
of NBC's trial and error and I am a man
pushing 50 in a Mexican Jersey with a
Mexican flag on my face like I'm three
come here with I actually thought about
bringing some of my corn Husker gear I
have a oh no you can go to like I was at
we were at I think it was Coney Island
with my wife and there were stuffed corn
cops with faces on them that you could
win like you tossed a ring yes and I
spent so much money they're tossing the
rings and never winning you know that
core cup that the the young person
actually Brooklyn don't take pity on too
many people now show you like I was just
clearly showing such such sad emotion
and like and recognized that like $40 is
way too much to pay for this corn whose
corn cob but he is uh he is my corn cob
he's robear bob the corn cob oh my god I
dress him in Nebraska gear and I almost
brought him today but you know I didn't
I had this my first time feels like
that's a strong thing to walk you've
already shared too much with the story
already fair you don't need to bring the
visual evidence but maybe next time
there maybe next time trial and error
season - um funny program in which you
are playing a guess of fish out of water
lawyer this season in in South Carolina
correct yeah yeah fictional town in
South Carolina coaster heck okay kind of
like Pawnee Indiana if you're Parks and
Rec and you have Christian Chenoweth as
your client yeah and it looks pretty
messy yeah John Lithgow last season in
seasons one and two congratulations on
yeah thank you must be enjoying the hell
out of this thing
yeah it's honestly for me it's a dream
come true
you know I've been doing it a long time
I've done a lot of pilots that never
made it and you know I I I got into this
one at the you just kind of this one
kept her having done it for 15 years and
not having had a show where I was able
to put you know Gotham I was able to
come back kind of multiple seasons but
I'm not there very often on that show
sure a very big cast there and they're
lovely but I just haven't had a lot of
access and in that show and to have a
show that come back a second season it
has been rare for me and so to get to do
this season mmm is such a joy and it's
one of those things where everything
fell into place like not only is it a
character that they write to so well for
me where I get to do kind of everything
in the show I get to do comedy but I
also am the one that keeps the dramatic
era the dramatic narrative locked down
I'm the straight man I get to ham it to
the camera a lot I get to do a lot and
it's a real it's a real joy and then on
top of it this really strange and
peculiar mechanic in our show where if
we get to keep going on but even two
years is enough where I have the
opportunity to get to work with a
pedigree of actor that is just kind of
wild you know it's this attractive role
for someone in their position because
they're very they can work often and
they get to do a lot of things and get
them to make their own choices and so
someone like John let's go can come in
and do a season two have a lot of fun
and then leave you know he doesn't have
to sign a six or seven year contract and
and Kristen can do the same thing and so
if we're lucky enough to have a third
season in our fourth then there's only
there I can add two more stars you know
legends to this list of people that I've
had the joy of getting to work with so
closely and and I learned so much from
them and they've they've both been just
I can't you know what I say about them
cannot be positive enough too true to
tell you the truth well so lovely I
couldn't be more happy for you it was
fun having you on here please come back
and it's just as well as you weren't
around Gotham very much because I I'm
married to a patriot fan and brockman I
work with one every day he can't be
around Chiklis longer than five minutes
within five minutes we were and I'm a
Buffalo Bills fan and so instantly I was
like come on as if I haven't had to live
with this long enough check you know
I'm saying Buffalo Bills yeah yeah no
you can't come on
when they finally wind yes great it's
gonna be for me yes let me tell you
what's not gonna happen
oh come on now we've been Sifl didn't
you see the two of us we're supposed to
talk about good to see you sir thank you
so much for having Nikolas de agosto
on Twitter check out trial and error
premiering Thursday July 19th at 9 p.m.
Eastern time it'll be season two with
Nicolas and Kristen Chenoweth in a whole
cast that is worthy of you checking it
out
good to see you thank you so much for
that back in 60 seconds it's still
nil-nil Harry Kane's hair is getting a
little mussed up where does that palmate
when you need it the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience